Мій гість - Андрій Коболєв,
голова правління компанії "Нафтогаз України"
Пане Коболєв, дякую за інтерв'ю
і ласкаво просимо до програми
Нещодавно глава "Газпрому" Олексій Міллер заявив
що наступного року транзит російського газу через
Україну може суттєво знизитися
За його словами, йдеться
про зменшення транзиту в десять разів
Це пов'язано з введенням в експлуатацію газогонів "Турецький потік" і "Північний потік - 2" вже в 2019
Як ви прокоментуєте цю заяву?
В цій заяві нічого нового
Пригадую, як три-чотири роки тому заступник пана Міллера Олександр Медведєв
казав щось на кшталт
"швидше сонце та місяць поміняються місцями, ніж ми продовжимо транзит газу через Україну"
Тобто, Російська Федерація хоче
в будь-який спосіб, але обійти Україну
Ми розуміємо, що за цим проектом стоїть частково геополітична, частково військова логіка
Пізніше я поясню, чому так вважаю
У будь-якому разі пан Міллер
надто оптимістично дивиться
на здатність "Газпрому" завершити згадані проекти
Ми в "Нафтогазі" наполегливо працюємо над тим,
щоб пояснити нашим європейським партнерам
чому цей проект суперечить інтересам Європи
та є так званим троянським конем
за якого, якщо його таки збудують,
європейцям доведеться згодом
серйозно розплачуватися
Україна готова до такого різкого зниження транзиту російського газу?
Якщо казати у теорії
Адже це може статися в майбутньому
Коли саме – передбачити нереально
Це обговорюється не лише в "Нафтогазі",
а й у широких політичних колах України
Якраз нещодавно я був у парламенті,
де говорив про це з депутатами
У нас є теорія щодо того, чому Росія
перебуваючи в жалюгідному фінансовому стані
інвестує стільки грошей в проекти,
які ніколи не окупляться
Якщо ви поглянете на "Турецький потік"
і "Північний потік-2"
то обидва проекти з комерційного погляду виглядають не дуже доцільними. Дешевше...
- Маєте на увазі, для Росії?
- Для Росії.
Тобто, ви непокоїтеся за Росію?
Я непокоюся за Україну.
І я поясню, чому починаю свої аргументи
саме з цього пункту
Добре
"Газпром" досі має деякі атрибути комерційної компанії
наприклад, раду директорів
Вони повинні ухвалювати
комерційно обґрунтовані рішення
але все ж зазнають дуже сильного впливу з боку політиків, а конкретніше з боку Путіна
Вони вирішують реалізувати проекти,
що, як я вже казав,
із комерційного погляду є недоцільними
Тоді виникає питання: які ж справжні причини?
Ми маємо гіпотезу, на якій будемо наполягати
Я навмисно кажу: гіпотеза
і, чесно кажучи, сподіваюся
що ми ніколи не матимемо нагоди
перевірити її на практиці
Вона полягає в тому, що Росія прагне позбутися транзиту через Україну
з дуже простої причини причини
бо за наявності транзиту
повномасштабна військова агресія проти України обійдеться Москві дуже дорого
Уявімо найгірший сценарій, за яким Росія просто зараз розпочинає захоплення України
ми вважаємо, що, перевівши транзит з України кудись деінде
Путін, по суті, розчистить шлях для повномасштабної військової операції
яка зрештою призведе до того, що російські танки опиняться на східних кордонах таких країн
як Польща, Угорщина, Словаччина й Румунія
До слова, саме тому більшість цих країн...
Перепрошую, що перебиваю вас
але ви справді вважаєте, що цей сценарій, який видається мені абсолютно нереалістичним
є середньо- або довгостроковою
метою путінської влади?
Що Путін хоче припинити транзит
і почати повномасштабну війну?
Ви вважаєте, що такий сценарій можливий?
Ви оцінюєте його ймовірність як дуже високу?
Існує справді велика ймовірність
такого розвитку подій
У разі припинення транзиту газу
через Україну вона вища, ніж 50%
Це моя оцінка. До речі, якщо поглянути на те, що сталося з Кримом
на Донецьк і Луганськ, на катастрофу MH17,
на справу Скрипаля
всі ці докази змушують мене вважати, що такий сценарій дуже навіть можливий
Є й інший, м'якший сценарій
Призупинка транзиту через Україну може допомогти Путіну виграти війну в економічному плані
Якщо Росія припинить транзит газу через Україну
наскільки велику шкоду це завдасть
економіці вашої країни?
Приблизно три з гаком мільярди доларів
А щодо ВВП?
Десь між двома і трьома відсотками.
Так що це доволі значні обсяги
Йдеться про одноразове падіння?
Якщо транзит припиниться, це трапиться раз
і назавжди. І це буде дуже болюче
Але якщо повернутися до питань стратегії й тактики, ви згадали санкції..
Росія вже перебуває під санкціями
Так-так, про це і йдеться
Ймовірно, санкції можна посилити
Але, наскільки я розумію, представники російської еліти навчилися жити з цим фактом
Може, у них просто немає іншого вибору, не знаю
Але з точки зору Путіна - якщо
він вже під санкціями
то за умов збереження санкцій і посилення
бойових дій в Україні, що йому втрачати?
З цієї точки зору тактично така опція здається
дуже реалістичною і дуже ймовірною.
Тобто, в вашому уявленні путінська Росія
прагне придушити Україну економічно
І якщо транзит припиниться...
- ...або військово...
- ... то це буде можливо. Я правильно зрозуміла?
Так, щонайменше економічно - за м'якого сценарію
За жорсткого - йдеться про військові дії
Ви вже згадали "Північний потік-2".
І ви категорично проти цього проекту
Перед інтерв'ю я розмовляла
з кількома експертами
які кажуть, що цей проект
дуже вигідний для Німеччини
але загрожує втратами низці інших країн,
зокрема Україні, Польщі й Словаччині
Ви згодні з такими міркуваннями?
Я згоден, що Німеччина отримає з цього проекту чимало миттєвого зиску
Можете перерахувати, яких саме зисків?
На першому етапі німецька економіка отримає
газ за найдешевшою ціною в Європі
Це підвищить її конкурентоспроможність
Німеччина стане головним і єдиним газовим хабом для російського пального в Європі
Як відомо, зараз стратегія "Газпрому"
полягає в тому
щоб стати найвигіднішим постачальником
Тому в короткостроковій перспективі
Німеччина отримає з цього зиск
Що трапиться потім?
Знову ж таки, це неважко передбачити, бо Російська Федерація в минулому довгі роки чинила саме так
Мова про так звану тактику "розділяй і володарюй"
Пан Путін подзвонить у Польщу і скаже:
Хочете отримувати дешевший газ,
ніж отримує Німеччина?
Її економіка конкурентоспроможніша, ніж ваша,
і це не надто справедливо
Якщо хочете отримати таку ж конкурентну перевагу
пропоную заразом обговорити й інші питання
Потім він подзвонить у Словаччину, Угорщину
та інші країни Центральної й Східної Європи
Так він створить розкол
Якщо розколоти Європейський Союз, можна досягти багатьох геополітичних цілей
Тож цей короткостроковий зиск,
що його, як нам видається,
отримає німецька економіка
призведе до втрат на наступному етапі
бо такі подарунки не бувають безкоштовними
І яка ціна?
Для Німеччини ціною буде розкол в Євросоюзі.
Тобто, йдеться про політичну ціну?
На першому етапі ціна буде політичною
Німеччина втратить можливість апелювати
до концепції солідарності
Наприклад, з такої важливої теми, як мігранти
Я чув від представників багатьох центральноєвропейських країн
Німеччина просить нас дотримуватися принципу солідарності в питанні мігрантів
але коли мова заходить про газ,
то раптом усі принципи забуваються
Ми такого не розуміємо
Про це вже говорять
Крім того, коли Німеччина стане головною країною прийому газу і транзит через Україну припиниться,
Москва почне шантажувати Берлін так само,
як зараз шантажує Київ
Від німецьких політиків ми чуємо
що Німеччина – значно сильніший
політичний гравець, ніж Україна
тому з ними буде складніше грати в ті ж ігри,
що з Україною
Погоджуюсь
Поза сумнівом, Німеччина – значно потужніший геополітичний гравець
Втім, важче - не означає неможливо